- Les géoLagon et leur chalet
Airbnb.
- On annonce dans
cette publicité la construction
d'un village de chtifs
de type Airbnb à Sainte-Adèle.
Un projet accompagné
d'une première nord-américaine:
un lagon chauffé à 38 degrés
celsius, été comme hiver,
six fois la dimension
d'une patinoire de la LNH.
L'inspiration vient du réputé
Lagon bleu d'Islande.
C'est d'ailleurs à cet endroit
que nous avons rejoint
le développeur, l'ex-président
du Village Vacances Valcartier
et du parc Calypso.
LOUIS MASSICOTTE, propriétaire,
village hôtelier La Metsä
- Moi, je pense que les lagons
géothermiques, les bassins
chauffés comme il y en a
un derrière moi qui est
le Blue Lagoon comme en Islande,
je vous parle d'Islande
aujourd'hui, ce sont
les attractions du futur.
On va utiliser la géothermie
le plus possible, mais il y aura
des compléments d'énergie,
électrique par exemple.
- Mais pour cet ingénieur,
un tel projet au Québec risque
d'être très couteux en énergie.
PHILIPPE PASQUIER, professeur,
génies civil, géologique, mines
de Polytechnique
- Dans dmme
en Islande, on a directement
une eau chaude, qui est
naturellement produite
à 60-70 degrés celsius,
ça devient extrêmement facile,
ment-là, d'utiliser
de l'eau pour chauffer
un bassin. C'est finalementune t
de réinjection. Là, ce que
le promoteur se propose
de faire, parce que
des ressources géothermiques
de haute température, on n'en a
pas dans l'est du Canada, donc
le promoteur ce que
de faire, c'est d'utiliser
des thermopompes qui sont
alimentées à l'électricité
pour en fer
ces réservoirs à 38 degrés
celsius.
- Une pétition dénonçant
le lagon géothermique et
le complexe de cha
lancée il y a trois semaines
Plus de 2000 personnes l'ont
signée, dont Christine et
Jean-Jacques.
CHRISTINE CHABOT, résidente
de Sainte-Adèle
- L'environnement, on n'en tient
pas compte, je pense.Creuser...e
de toute la faune qui a là?
Qu'est-ce qui arrive au niveau
de l'élel'eau, où
est-ce qu'ils vont prendre
cette eau-là?
JEAN-JACQUES ALLOUIS, résident
de Sainte-Adèle
- Christine parle beaucoup
d'environnement, mais j'ai rien
qu'un seul mot pour ça:
mégalomanie.
- Dans la municipalité voisine,
Val-Morin, ce résident a aussi
de sérieuses réserves.
GUILLAUME MARTEL LASALLE,
résident de Val-Morin
- Des gens vont venir simplement
consommer, s'en aller avec
leur pick-up puis dépenser
de l'énergie parce que là ça vat
qui va falloir chauffer, ça
apportera rien à la communauté.
- Les installations seront
construites en bordure
du P'tit Train du Nord,
à proximité du sommet Olympia
et de l'ancienne p
La Rolland. Le terrain, boisé,
est déjà zoné comme
récréotouristique
MICHÈLE LALONDE, mairesse
de Sainte-Adèle
- C'est sûr que s'il rencontre
toutes les règles, on peut pas
refuser. Par contre, on pourrait
peut-êr au niveau
de l'environnement que ce n'est
pas possible lagon, mais
que les chalets, ça l'est.
Le projet, si il rencontre
les normes d'urban
de la ville, ça va nous faire
plaisir de l'accueillir parce
qu'évidemment on a rien contre
les projets d'envergure.
- Déjà, le projet va de l'avant.
- Oui, pour les Laurentides,
ça a été pré-vendu à 100%
ures exactement.
- Sans que la municipalité n'ait
encore donné son feu vert
au lagon artificiel.
- À l'heure actuelle on n'a pas
de dossier ouvert encore et on
n'a pas, non plus... on n'a pas
de demande de permis,
aucune demande de permis.
- Quoiqu'il en soit,
Louis Massicotte a de grandes
ambitions pour la suite.
Après Sainte-Adèle, ce sera
l'Estrie et la région de Québec.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Mon